equilateral trapezoid isosceles
tetrahedron I've never seen a mind like
the one your daughter has you have to
see
which she becomes Catherine we all go
end up unemployed riding around in this
pilot jump you're welcome to up the
16-month all sit in the back of the bus
you have identification number we just
don't know way to work at NASA I had no
idea they heard quite a few women
working in the space program you know
we're putting a human on top of a
missile shooting into space and it's
never been done before
I need a mathematician they can look
beyond the numbers math if it doesn't
yet exist before the Russians plant a
flag from the damn moment you have
someone yeah there's a gap of that she
can handle women numbers you couldn't
run from don't embarrass me this wasn't
empty last night I'm sorry I'm not that
Colonel Jam is a tall glass of water
he's coming over now why would he be
doing that tells Mary wait a minute Oh
Jonathan slice up a third of what you
already have a slam your computer nest
and let women handle that sorted that
women do some things at NASA mr. Johnson
and it's not because we're Laius Kurtz
it's because we wait glasses
we go from being our father's daughters
to our husbands wives to our babies
mothers every night for three honking
out with Mama gone for 12 and a half
days no but it felt like that I don't
like it too me too
it's crunch time in 14 days astronauts
won't be here for training everything we
do can matter to their wives to their
children I believe is gonna matter to
the whole damn country my gals are ready
we can do the work that's John Glenn
what do you ladies do for NASA calculate
your knowledge in handy sir engineer and
I'm proud as the devil to be working
with you it's equal rights I have no
right to cease fire and there's no
protocol for women attending there's no
protocol for man circling the Earth
either sir every time we have a chance
to get ahead they move the finish line
every roof time we all get there
together we don't get there at all
let's give it no NASA and given up on
good old-fashioned brainpower
let me ask you if you a white male would
you wish to be an engineer I wouldn't
have to I'd already be one don't you
know that we're able